thanks to the memorable characters they
brought to life on the big screen and on
our TVs these actors will never really
leave us in fact they'll always be there
exactly the way we remember them they'll
never be more than a few clicks away
former child actor John Paul steyr who
played a young Klingon on Star Trek The
Next Generation died on January 1st at
the age of 33 story began professionally
acting at the age of four and was the
first actor to play Alexander then
mostly Klingon son of Worf on Star Trek
The Next Generation he portrayed the
character in one episode reunion and
other actors went on to play the role at
various ages why can't I stay with you
deserve he's perhaps best known for
playing Brett Butler's eldest son on the
sitcom grace under fire from 1993 until
leaving the show in 1996 you're not
sitting up here making plans to be
dysfunctional are you what's
dysfunctional
he later said he quit acting in part
because of Butler's erratic behavior and
controversy surrounding the series his
death was announced on the Facebook page
of the rock band problems in which story
are saying under the name Johnny P Jules
for about a year former child actor
Joseph Wayne Miller made his
breakthrough in the 1995 comedy
heavyweights according to TMZ he died in
his sleep On January 9th at the age of
36 Miller played the character of salami
Sam and heavyweights
which was co-written and produced by
Judd Apatow in a statement to page six
Apatow said we could not have loved
spending time with him more he made
everyone around him so happy
what a terrible loss hey what's up I'm
virtually verne troyer stood at 2 feet 8
inches and was born with achondroplasia
dwarfism a condition that causes
cartilage to not properly convert to
bones often resulting in under sized
arms and legs in 2012 he told Jonathan
Ross you're born kind of proportioned
and yeah you look pretty much normal
except for being small he grew up in an
Amish community in Michigan and achieved
fame when he debuted opposite Mike
in 1999 Austin Powers The Spy Who
shagged me Troyer had more than 50
acting credits in movies and on
television including roles as Griphook
and Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone and coach punch jerk-off in the
love guru Verne Troyer died on April
21st at the age of 49 according to
people his death was noted by the
coroner as possibly being a suicide via
alcohol poisoning an announcement on
Troyer's Facebook page read it is with
great sadness and incredibly heavy
hearts to write that Vern passed away
today Vern was an extremely caring
individual he wanted to make everyone
smile be happy and left actress Pamela
Gidley passed away at the age of 52 on
April 16th dying peacefully in her New
Hampshire home an actress since 1986 kid
Lee's debut roles in the skateboarding
movie thrashin in which she starred
alongside childhood friend
sherilyn fenn and Josh Brolin says they
pay a thousand dollars to the winner
surace it's no little race to down him
early in her career the model turned
actress played an Android in the cult
sci-fi comedy movie cherry 2000 she went
on to have a notable role in the 1992
Twin Peaks prequel film fire walk with
me in 1992 Gidley had a regular role on
the buddy cop series angel street on CBS
starring opposite Robin Givens as a
Chicago homicide detective her last
credited role was in Twin Peaks the
missing pieces a long-lost compilation
of extended and deleted scenes from Twin
Peaks fire walk with me perhaps best
known for playing Lois Lane in the
Superman film series actress Margot
Kidder died on May 13th 2018 at her home
in Montana
she was 69 years old Kidder moved to Los
Angeles shortly after graduating high
school in order to pursue acting in the
late 60s the whole idea was to get
wildly out of control and see how far
you could go before you crashed in 1972
she moved to New York City and scored a
role in the Brian DePalma movie sisters
a critically acclaimed psychological
thriller but her on-screen coupling was
Superman played by Christopher Reeve
really put her on the map
should we get on to the interview yes
the romance between the two characters
played out across four films between
1978 and 1987 Kidder was known for a
variety of other roles with performances
in the horror movies black Christmas and
the Amityville Horror the actress
suffered from mental illness all her
life and a 1996 bipolar episode led to a
high-profile disappearance she opened up
about her struggle to Canada a.m. in
2003 attempted suicide several times
yeah I just always assumed I'd never get
to be this old I'm a grandmother now as
she told the Idaho Press Tribune in 2017
she remained actively involved in causes
she believed in protesting against war
and the excesses of the energy industry
I've mostly been doing political
activism I was at Standing Rock in a
tent for four months Anthony Bourdain
was a writer presenter producer and
performer who helped shape how we see
international food culture he died on
June 8th in France at the age of 61
Bourdain rose to prominence in 2000 on
the back of his best-selling book
Kitchen Confidential adventures in the
culinary underbelly by the time it was
published he'd already gathered more
than 20 years of experience in the
kitchen and his unapologetic attitude
and confessional style helped endear him
to a large audience do toxins from what
the book was adapted into a television
series in 2005 starring Bradley Cooper
as a bad boy chef based on Bourdain
himself that image helped make Bourdain
a charismatic presence on the
international food scene he started
appearing on television as the host of
Food Network's a cook store an
adaptation of Bourdain second book
Bourdain continued his career as a host
with the series no reservations the
layover and Anthony Bourdain parts
unknown his notoriety also led to
winking cameo appearances in film and
television with for Dane appearing as
himself in the 2015 film the big short
it's not old fish it's a whole new thing
that it's a CDF
he was decorated with awards from the
entertainment industry for his work
earning five Emmys and a Peabody Award
where Jane tragically died of an
apparent suicide by hanging his body
discovered by a friend and colleague in
his France hotel room on the morning of
June 8 during his life there chef made
no secret of his struggles with
depression and history of
self-destructive behavior remarking in
one 2016 interview I should have died in
my 20s Burt Reynolds was a movie star
known for his displays of genial charm
and unique charisma over the course of
his storied 50-year career he died on
September 6 at the age of 82 born on
February 11th 1936 Reynolds began his
career on Broadway and television shows
he went on to leave his mark on American
cinema through appearances in a number
of successful films including
deliverance The Longest Yard and Smokey
and the Bandit we have a big chance a
big chance to make his outsized persona
and sex symbol status made him a fixture
of pop culture in the 1970s and 80s and
he enjoyed wild success between 1978 and
1982 as the industry's top grossing
movie star despite his natural talents
as a box-office draw Reynolds spent much
of his career seeking validation as an
actor rarely earning much critical
respect for his performances in his 2015
memoir he claimed he didn't start
challenging himself as a performer until
he was older being more interested in
leading an exciting life and cultivating
a body of work for his work in Boogie
Nights he was nominated for an Academy
Award for Best Supporting Actor he lost
the Oscar but won a Golden Globe he also
won two Golden Globes and an Emmy for
his work on the comedy series evening
shade we got this far somehow you can
believe so
October is a month that's been
associated with the walking dead for
many years now but in 2018 it brought
unwelcome news for fans of the show just
one day before the ninth season premiere
on October 7th actor Scott Wilson passed
away after a battle with cancer the
actor who portrayed farmer Hershel
Greene between 2011 and 2014 was 76
Wilson was a lead cast member in seasons
three and four and he became a popular
figure among the cast and crew his
passing was announced on The Walking
Dead's official Twitter account our
thoughts are with his family and friends
rest in paradise Scott we love you in an
official statement
AMC said that Hershel was always at the
emotional core of the Walking Dead and
that he continues to inform our
characters choices to this day long
after his death if you're from
northeastern America you'll probably
recognize the late James Karen's face
even if you never knew his name until
now the character actor will be forever
remembered as the Pathmark man because
of an advertising campaign for Pathmark
supermarkets that lasted almost two
decades
so come to pass one cover to number one
24 hours a day and savings overall karen
actually lived in los angeles miles away
from the nearest Pathmark store he
passed away at the age of 94 in his LA
home the Pennsylvania native also popped
up in hundreds of Hollywood movies over
the years including Return of the Living
Dead and 1982 s poltergeist good buddy
George Clooney claims Karen once tricked
him into writing his obituary
prematurely saying he just wanted to
know what everybody thought about him
while he was still around he got a bunch
of people to do it Emma chambers the
British actress known for the romantic
comedy Notting Hill died February 21st
at the age of 53 according to the BBC
she died of natural causes this is one
of those key moments in life and it's
possible you can be really genuinely
cool and I I'm going to fail just to
hundred percent her breakthrough came in
1994 when she starred in the BBC
miniseries based on Charles Dickens's
Martin Chuzzlewit
she also played village church Verger
alice tinker on the popular BBC comedy
The Vicar of Dibley appearing in alt
episodes of the show through 2007
American audiences probably remember her
best as honey the eccentric younger
sister of Hugh Grant's character in
1999's Notting Hill
she also played Helen Yardley on the TV
series how do you want me from 1998 to
Stanley became such a beloved figure not
only with comics fans but among everyone
in general with his down-to-earth style
and funky mannerisms we all knew he
wasn't in great health but still in
November 2018 when his own epic art came
to an end at the age of 95 we were all
crushed born in 1922 pleased first gig
at the age of 17 was as a gopher at
timely publications comic books were far
from mainstream at the time but the
success of Superman / DC comics gave
owner Martin Goodman hope he tasked Lee
with writing a story for Captain America
number three and within the span of two
years the youngster had become
editor-in-chief at time Lee later known
as Marvel Comics from his cluttered
office in Manhattan Lee helped create
numerous classic comic book characters
and superhero teams from spider-man and
black panther 2 the Fantastic Four and
of course the Avengers Lee famously made
short but sweet cameo appearances in
Marvel movies with his personal favorite
being the time Thor got him blind drunk
in Avengers age of Ultron a shield
he told playboy in 2014 keep moving
forward and if it's time to go it's time
nothing lasts forever it's difficult to
overstate just how much Hollywood owes
to Penny Marshall who died on December
17th at the age of 75 due to
complications from diabetes her status
as a legend would have been cemented if
she had only been known for being one
half of the popular TV duo Laverne and
Shirley but that was only the beginning
as her impact on television and film
went much much further she became a true
trailblazer for women in show business
when she directed the Tom Hanks star
making vehicle big which was the first
female directed film to gross more than
100 million dollars and just a few years
later she directed a league of their own
which the Library of Congress selected
for preservation in the National Film
registry in 2012 for its cultural
sniff Achatz sadly these aren't the only
actors who left us in 2018 here's a look
at some of the many stars who enhanced
our lives before leaving us all too soon
Jerry Van Dyke
Reggie Kathie John Mahoney David Ogden
Stiers Stephen Hawking
DeSean Monique Brown Donnelly Rhodes
Connie Sawyer Mark Salling Robert doubt
Oh John Gavin Debbie Lee Carrington
Dorothy Malone Vic Damone Harry Anderson
our lee ermey Micky Jones Nanette Fabray
susan anspach joseph Campanella Robert
Mandan Eunice gayson Stan Lee Anderson
Tab Hunter
Elmarie Windell Mary Carlisle Charlotte
Rae
Stefan Karl Steffensen robin Leach
Barbara Harris Clint Walker
Vanessa Marquez Susan brown
Carroll Shelley Bradford Dillman Doreen
Tracy
Christopher Kennedy Lawford Bill Daley
Peter Benson Derrick O'Connor Gloria
Jean Allen and McCleary Peter doughnut
al Matthews James Jimmy Karen Diana Sol
Avon sewer Marin mazzie Jackson Odell
Ricky J Peter Masterson Frank Adonis if
you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please call the
National Suicide Prevention lifeline at
one eight hundred two seven three talk
that number again is
you